vuelven los embajadores este jueves el
presidente de venezuela nicolás maduro
nombró al ex canciller félix plasencia
como su representante diplomático en
bogotá lo hizo en el marco del proceso
de normalización de relaciones entre
ambos países y ya la cancillería de
venezuela ha pedido el beneplácito a la
cancillería de colombia
y pronto estará en bogotá
en respuesta el presidente de colombia
gustavo petro también nombró a su
embajador en caracas es armando
benedetti ex senador y la persona que le
llevó la agenda en la campaña electoral
estas serán sus misiones restablecer la
institucionalidad que existía desde
décadas antes para que los dos pueblos
hermanos puedan parecer sus derechos
garantizar sus libertades y lograr que
entre colombia y venezuela se pueda
construir riqueza para ambos pueblos
además de la normalización los
embajadores se enfrentan a la reapertura
de la frontera de más de dos mil
kilómetros que comparten y que lleva
cerrada el paso de vehículos desde 2015
también a la colaboración de
inteligencia entre ejércitos para
combatir narcotráfico paramilitares y
también a la guerrilla de ln el ex
comisionado de paz colombiano daniel
garcía-peña dijo a france 24 que la
normalización ayudará a un posible
acuerdo de paz con la última guerrilla
de colombia
político distinto y sin duda la
reapertura con venezuela es un factor
positivo y razón con la de uso posible
con el adn las relaciones se rompieron
en 2019 el ex presidente de colombia
iván duque reconoció como su homólogo en
venezuela a juan guaidó y calificó de
dictadura al gobierno de nicolás madura